since i last talked to you you did turn
21 so happy belated
hey thank you i'll make this one kind of
quick but you did take some heat
for a party parties yeah
um a lot of influencers calling you out
because of the
continued parties yeah the influencers
that also attend other parties they
called me out yeah i know well that's
what i was gonna say do you have
anything to say to them and
do you have any regrets about these
parties i
fully regret the party i didn't expect
that many people to come
but the thing that bothers me is these
influencers that'll
these influencers that'll like call me
out and say like why are you partying
where mass social distance all this
[ __ ]
when they don't even practice it
themselves practice what you preach
right so you feel like there's some
hypocrisy they're all they're all liars
all these people are liars and i hate it
but i do regret the party i already
spoke about it i don't really want to
get into too much detail about the
the party because it's like yeah that
was a huge [ __ ] up in my career
just to end this on a positive note and
for all your fans out there
will you sort of cut back on throwing
these bigger parties like did you get
that yeah okay so party animal is tamed
for a little bit
that's good to know you do seem to be
working out a lot which i think is a
very healthy alternative to
having parties how much are you actually
working out
or how much is just like making tick
tocks in there and then
i work out like five times five times a
week i want to get like huge all the
sway boys we
we've like did a pretty significant body
transformation in three months
but we're all trying to get to like i
don't know what body we can compare to
it let me think
a little bit bigger than the dolan twins
like that the dolan twins how jack they
are just a little bit
bigger i did see tyler cameron was
working
out with somebody yeah came over
yesterday yeah how was
how did you guys meet him and how did
that sort of happen that was actually my
first time meeting him in person
but i knew him through instagram like
we've played virtual beer pong together
and he even even said he came he comes
up to us he's like dude you guys got
bigger and i was like
yeah so funny are you trying to recruit
him into this way house
we're not looking for any new members
right now now all right so the cap is on
is on sway right now yeah just for a
little bit yeah
[Music]
you said the party animal is kind of
dead for right now
before you talked about tamed not dead
all right tamed before you talked about
how your sobriety was super important to
you
is that something that's still important
to you
the sobriety thing yeah it's always good
to give your your body a rest or i can't
say right now i'm sober
i mean like right now in this physical
yeah i'm sober but i'm saying like i i
do
smoke weed every once in a while and i
do drink
but that's it like you've had a kind of
crazy couple of months you had the
breakup you turned 21
what do you feel like you learned about
yourself that 21 is gonna be a crazy
year
i feel i definitely need to work on um
not being as problematic i feel as if
i'm a really nice guy but when i
do these sarcastic remarks online about
other influencers and stuff it does make
me seem like an apple
yeah um so i'm gonna chill out on that
i'm 21 now i don't need to worry about
these people
no but that's like i think that's a nice
thing to be self-aware
yeah about and like there are good i've
been chilling for the past month i
haven't gotten into
anything there are misconceptions about
you anything that you want
to clear up um your platform
i feel like as as more people watch me
across all my platforms not just
highlight the negatives that i've done
in my past
or in the current i feel like they would
they would understand that deep down i
i am a pretty nice guy like and i have
really good intentions for everything
that i'm doing
yeah you have a big heart yeah but low
key
a low key what do your parents think
my mom always gets on me about that yeah
she's like you turn into an la guy and
i'm like i know i need to come back to
maryland for a little bit
you